big box bully you can talk about get
back go get a page
please please stop humming big box
bullying and find tiny books in today's
all right kitty jus do you mark Wow okay
all right okay all right okay okay that
was my crotch I'm trying to say it's
safe in here if you could just stop
killing me for - okay you're getting a
little close to my face what did I just
get done saying see if I can make it all
the way up to seven without sucking oh
wait I'm the champion of suck Wow the
heck happened I mean it's obvious what
happened my torso got ripped in half a
mile okay well we're all done here
everybody pack up go home okay bye Oh
secret win oh here I thought that it was
gonna be an obstacle that I need to go
through but apparently there's a secret
oh so sing apparently there's a secret
okay whatever doing legit cougar smack
oh no I don't have time that's up on my
butt out directly in the butt oh how am
i dead oh don't worry son
[Music]
marklar hard once again people are
making Margit are impossible
I'll show well alright well I okay
Morgan Blair overdose
oh my god it's zero its death dice
overdose I can't speak oh god that
almost got me I need to get my black bar
all the way up only people who have seen
this video actually know that reference
and I'm not being terribly offensive Oh
legs stuck under uh-huh
I'm gonna win this on the first try I'm
gonna win a can't be level on the first
try Oh
give give yes yes I know what else I
wanted everyone is so badly oh it's
right there oh god it's so tantalizingly
close what else can I do
I've done my best I did my best
what from me my best oh well how did I
avoid that and this is loop don't do
drugs kids eat your milk
dude smoke weed everyday' don't do drugs
watch this guy's I'm so smart oh so I
did not do this right now
let me just graze my ass cheeks longer
spikes there I can still survive if I
just don't impale myself anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a winner even though I'm horribly
maimed and probably gonna bleed out
right but I didn't really die
how was the joke mark wall Margot are
the visitor by many legend who is also a
very talented maker of happy wheels
levels press space once an up arrow oh
I'm a Slytherin oh I'm not a Slytherin
I'm probably like a Gryffindor or
something but don't worry it'll speed up
oh I believe you I believe you I mean
this blazing speed as of right now I
seem to be big enough as it is everybody
on board the death train next stop
horrible nightmares in next evolution I
win Oh No oh wait so are Caspian mini
legend working together or are Caspian
mini legends the same person I'm
confused now either way thank you guys
so much for making it and thank you for
congratulating me on 6 million
subscribers
our goal is CP this levels for you it's
about a CPU temperature well that was
not radical Larry that was impending
death that I managed to avoid think well
ok then I didn't know that wasn't again
ok
I'm missing all the things that you're
trying to tell me because I'm
expeditiously going through this level
very quickly
I don't ok then I'm not dead yet but
what is the hell is even memory but our
fun oh the fun started before I got
there how about you hold back your fun
meter okay well just can you pause the
fun for just a little bit ah my son
didn't have very much fun oh I'm in the
wrong character to have enough fun in
this ball pit but I'm having fun either
way
balls in a pit bag black arrow ruff
Wow I'm gonna consider that a victory
because I was clearly in the winner's
circle before you douche this all up for
me okay maybe I didn't win maybe I'll
try to Oh here that's you wanted me to
be here
oh I wanted to be over there but here's
fine thank you
it's a booty bus everybody on board to
boogie bus oh yeah Oh tiny box Tim
driving to boogie bus and San Flyers
humping the boogie bus again
sorry every other me okay okay thank you
thank you Tim for the lovely ride I'm
gonna get out of here now thank you
markiplier mustache kill them all I
guess okay how do i how i go i don't
like oh this is how i go go war stache
go thanks tiny bucks Tim thanks for
encouraging me to murder vvvvvv that was
a game that I never finished but it was
a good one alright okay that's happening
everyone's dying it's okay though
because happy I killed them all
Oh silence are those the end of the
level
but I guess I don't sir little stinker
well tell me your destiny well I sure
hope the level doesn't end in just about
two seconds
[Music]
Marga bill are king of the werecats that
is exactly like scribble Nettie's king
of the werecats and that is exactly not
like Skrill Nettie's king of the
werecats
what the hell am i doing forward back
break chef get my oh here we go whoa
okay I'm so sorry
PS harpus what the hell did I do okay
the hell did they do this chorus
burritos run okay Oh Bob oh sorry excuse
me knocked your head around a little bit
off that tree you watched my live stream
who wants to be raised in Mario it kills
me he'll cheat oh my god eunuch unicorn
droid 56 holy crap that was awesome
hello tiny buxom you are sent on a
mission to kill everyone press face
chart and then go kill everyone well
that doesn't seem like a good thing to
do but hey if that's my mission I'll
accept it because I'm scuse me everybody
sorry sorry about your leg sorry sorry
sorry sorry
[Music]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video